GoDz: ...they've gotta get the throne here. TP in from BurNIng with the boots of travel.
He's got an omnislash and who is he gonna go for? Onto Arteezy.
Omnislash comes out...
Arteezy's gonna get sliced and diced!
Onto your zai Clockwerk as well! It's a team wipe!
Secret have lost game two.
We're going to a game three.
GoDz: My friends showed me Dota
I can still remember the guy who I was
kind of playing other random custom
games on Warcraft 3 with. It was initially,
I was living in Singapore, when I was like,
15, 14 years old. I started playing like
random custom games on Warcraft 3 with some of my school friends, just in
like LAN cafes after school and stuff
or on weekends, so that got me into
Warcraft 3, then I kind of got into like
the Warcraft 3 classic melee mode
and then one day, one of the guys I was
playing with was like "you have to try this
game Dota." I initially hated it, like I
knew it was kind of -
there was very much this
just feeling around it, like it was so
popular and big at the time, but it was just
like "oh, it's not like a serious game" or
it's like a... it's kinda like the new..
I guess, like the way Dota players talk about League was like the way my group
of friends kind of talked about Dota then
because we all played Warcraft 3, which
was like the pure game, I guess, and
Dota was just like a spin-off custom
game, so it wasn't to be taken seriously.
They're just going to get the throne off of this!
Holy sh**!
Cloud9 have lost game two.
I can't believe it!
Before kind of getting
into the Australian scene as a manager and kind of, I guess... caster, event organizer
whatever it may be, I was actually playing. I was playing with the Natural 9 guys.
I played the four position support role for the team,
so I, initially always just wanted to be one
of the pro players.
I was, I guess, that's kind of how
it started for a lot of people, just by
either playing too much casually for fun
and then getting into casting or playing
in a kind of more serious level, that
was always at least somewhat a dream of mine.
Dennis Gonzales [interviewer]: Why did your pro career not work out?
GoDz: I was kind of...
using Dota as...
using my university probably as a cover-up for attempting to play Dota competitively.
But, I wasn't really going to classes. I
was kind of struggling, and then, I ended
up moving on and kind of dropping my
studies for the time being, which is when
I started working and juggling - and that was when Dota 2 came out as well and I was
like "okay I want to make a big push with Dota 2." I started playing with Natural 9
guys, who were the best in Australia, who
ended up actually going to TI2,
so unfortunately, I was juggling trying to
play with them and, at that point, my
parents had stopped supporting me because I wasn't at university, I wasn't studying
anymore, so I had to have a full-time job,
so I was working in restaurants, bars trying
to just feed myself... I still remember
a time where I'd like go through all my
pairs of jeans to just try and find like a
few dollar coins to just like pay for a meal
or something.
That was what my life was like, at one point, just because
of how much I just wanted to play
Dota, I wanted to really make it. But I
still remember when the team talked to me and was like "look this isn't gonna work out,
like you haven't got the time to commit" and in some ways also
just questioned my ability as well and
my ability to commit to the team, and also my
ability as an individual player.  I
think my performance suffered as a
result and they were like "look we want to try someone else out - we think we can do
better with him." And that kind of crushed
me, at the time, but obviously not everyone
can be a pro player, there's a lot of
things that get in the way and unfortunately it
didn't work out for me, but it amazingly
led to something else which was just as
good and challenging in its own ways.
GodZ: I think you're definitely generalizing.
swindlezz: Jesus Christ! I'm gonna stab you with this pen!
GoDz: Look at TI! Hao suddenly busts out a Luna.
Everyone's like "whoa, Hao's suddenly picking Luna at TI in an elimination match?
And oh, Vici Gaming are winning with Luna."
swindlezz: I'll give you that. I'll give you that. That's a good point.
GoDz: Initially, I was kind of organizing some small... I guess you could call them
amateur tournaments, but as far as the
Australian scene went it had all the best
teams just because there was like not
much prize money in it, so I would like
kind of help organize the tournaments
for the teams and people wanted to watch
it so, I was like, "okay." This is when XSplit and Twitch were getting big, so I
figured I could just easily make an
account and started streaming the games
and as someone who just had played a ton competitively, loved the game, was just
addicted to the game, to be frank, I was
like "okay, I want to talk about this and
people want to listen," so I just started
going to casting. I ended up joining
Gosu Gamers as one of their main Dota
casters and they gave me a ton of
support, helped get me to my first LAN
tournament in Thailand as a Dota caster and
about six months to a year later, I
actually got offered my first kind of
esports job in Thailand, where I was
based for about six months...
GoDz: Hi Kickstarter, I'm David Parker.
LD: And I'm David Gorman.
GoDz:  Together, we are Beyond The Summit.
GoDz: Beyond The Summit was kind of
just like a placeholder name for I guess
the project and initially was maybe a more of a hobby,
but then it kind of transitioned into this
big kind of project - an idea of mine -
where I wanted to do something to really
help grow the scene and be more involved
myself, but also bring in other people
who had kind of similar goals, ambitions
and LD was someone who had reached out to me and kind of heard some good things about.
He had been casting with Luminous
over at Dota Commentary, so I just took a
leap of faith and said "okay, you're from
the US, have a good streaming set-up,
you can stream in like 720p as opposed to the 480p or something we were streaming in
from Australia" and said "look want to
join me and be the official caster for
the TI2 Eastern qualifiers?"
GoDz: ...heroes like Prophet and Morphling. They just cannot stop this push."
LD: Yeah, this is what we talked
about in the pre-game is WE don't really
want to fight these pushes head on.
GoDz: That was, I guess, the first time
I had talked to LD and casted with him.
We hopped into the first cast having never even spoken together and that was just kind
of how things worked at the time. You
just Skype in and say "look,
we're going to cast together and this is how it's going to work..."
It was a great, great experience. We
worked really well together and then
later that year we met at TI2 and
everything went really well from there.
GoDz: The Summit 2 was when we had [sighs] all kinds of problems.
PCs not working, internet not working, power not working, I don't know,
the list goes on. That was like a
disaster of an event for us.
We made the resolution like "we're
not working with PC Partner again,
we had like all these PCs provided and like half of them failed. And then,
like luckily - I think Red Bull it was -
bailed us out and brought trucks
filled with some of their PCs from their
office down and we were like "Thank God,
we can actually run an event now."
We  had all kinds of... I think even DDoS issues throughout the day.
The stream was just a
nightmare, everything about The Summit 2 was just...
[sigh]
It was a rough event. But we made it
through and the teams they came back
they trusted us that we were gonna fix
everything.
F***ing never again, man.
Never again will we do an event like that.
I think by then my parents were fairly accepting
when I finally relocated for BTS. It was
probably the years preceding that where
they were very, I guess, non-supportive of
the whole what I was doing.
Largely because they didn't and partly
because they didn't understand it,  but
largely because also I didn't
communicate what I was doing as something -
I kind of, I guess, knew they wouldn't
initially accept. So rather than trying
to explain and prove to them like "this
matters a lot to me that I'm gonna do
this, it's gonna be successful", I said "I'm
just gonna do it and then they'll have
to learn to deal with it." The first
LAN tournament I went to in Thailand, I didn't even
tell them I was going to Thailand and it happened to be when there was a bad storm coming
coming or something and they found out on Facebook that I was there and they contacted me
like "holy s***, you're in Thailand!? What the hell are you doing!?  Are you okay?
Are you safe?" So it was... I was
immature, at the time, so
in hindsight that was probably not the best way of approaching it, but I'm really
happy where we are now.
My parents... when I first...
The first TI I went to in 2012,
my Mum was there.
I told her, just said "come, come and see what this is and that
was around the time where they knew I
was at least somewhat serious about what
I was doing and it was starting to
kind of build-up and become a thing that
I could do more consistently - I was
getting paid to do it.  So, my Mum saw me
casting or on the panel there in front
of thousands of people at Benaroya Hall
and she was kind of finally had, I think
bit of a realization, like "okay, this
is not just... competitive gaming is a thing." Like up until that point, my parents
had no idea what it was, they just knew
I'm broadcasting online and people
watching and maybe I make some ad
revenue. They at least understood that
this is what I was gonna do, so whether I
was going to succeed or not? I didn't
even know, I guess. I was hopeful,
I knew I wasn't going to be a complete failure, but I know if this was something
that was going to last one year, five years, ten years... And, I think from my parents' point-of-view,
they had the same feelings, but
they were just like "well, he's gonna do
it" and they were supportive, at that point.
GoDz: Next for me? Let's see, where do I want to go?
I'd love to kind of be able to
dedicate more time to personal growth,
as an individual outside of Dota,
I feel like so much of what's defined me
over the last two years has just been Dota related, but also, I do want to grow as a caster, as an analyst.
I feel like there's a lot
more I can learn about the game and do
within the game, so I want to challenge
myself, but I also want to make sure that I
continue to find that balance, so that I
can also, I guess,
maintain a decent life balance and then
be able to be more productive and make
sure that events continue to go well
for us.